health care should be unbelievably cheap
right it's a capital intensive almost
zero marginal cost business and if you
look at any other industry that is a
terrible business model I'm Camille
Foster for a reason TV and I'm here with
David gold Hill the CEO of the game show
network
mr. gold hill is also the author of a
much discussed Atlantic article from
2009 how American health care killed my
father that article has now become a
book called catastrophic care Mr Gold
Hill has been generous enough to join us
to discuss some of the ideas in that
book and his unique take on what is
wrong with America's health care system
mr. gold thanks so much for joining us
David thanks so much for joining us I
wanted to begin by asking you to give us
a little bit of context about how you
got interested in the issue and your
your sort of unique perspective on it
and how your experience with your father
sort of brought you there well
specifically my dad walked into a
hospital one afternoon with a bit of
shortness of breath he was admitted for
observation the fear with a man his age
was 82 at the time as always
pneumonia but within 24 hours had
acquired what became a series of
infections in that hospital that killed
him five weeks later without his leaving
I probably would have been like any
other family member then just dealing
with the grief and the sort of disbelief
except coincidentally there was a piece
in The New Yorker a month later about a
guy who'd been running around the
country Peter Pronovost an expert in
healthcare safety with a series of
fairly simple steps a protocol for
cleanliness and hygiene that in
hospitals that had tried it had reduced
this type of infection rate by
two-thirds to three-quarters and it was
almost costless it was just a really a
matter of procedures and discipline and
an oversight I needed a hard time
getting hospitals to sign up for this
that's also where I learned a statistic
that more Americans should know which is
that roughly a hundred thousand
Americans are estimated to die from
preventable infections received in
hospitals and the numbers for total
medical error related death for all
causes
or up near 200,000 which makes this one
of the leading causes of death in the
country is strangely enough as a
businessman who had just been through a
personal tragedy that set off an alarm
bell because I died help run a movie
theater Chen and in our movie theater
chain we had a simple rule if a soda
spilled someone had to clean it up in
five minutes or someone got in trouble
and it wasn't because we were afraid of
liability it's because we were afraid
that you and your wife would be there on
date night and finally have gotten a
babysitter for the kids and the first
thing you see when you walk into our
movie theaters there's a soda spill and
I thought to myself if we can do that to
get you not to go to the theater across
the street why on earth are hospitals
having such a hard time doing what seems
like fairly simple cost-free things to
save lives and that Camille is what got
me interested in this whole question of
what's really going on in our health
care system yeah and and from reading
your book I mean the word incentives
comes up a great deal it sounds as
though there is a direct correlation or
connection I should say between the way
that we are financing health care in
this country and the fact that we are
not taking those simple steps to try to
alleviate what is a really profound
problem you contextualize that by saying
that an elderly person is more likely to
die going to the hospital for treatment
than a soldier in Iraq or Afghanistan
I mean obviously there's no disrespect
intended for the extraordinary danger
our young men and women go into in war
it's just to make the point that even
the most dangerous sacrifice we can ask
a citizen to make has a better more
Tylar of a lesser mortality rate I
should say then a senior going into a
hospital which is a pawn the fundamental
argument I made it is whether removing
us as the real consumer in health care
putting someone in between us and
providers whether it's insurers whether
it's Medicare whether it's Medicaid
hasn't so completely turned the
incentives in the system on their head
so that what we see now is that the best
way to make money in health care is to
price high provide excess service be
sloppy about safety under invest in
service which includes information
technology and lack the type of
we see in everything else that the
incentives actually point everyone's
behavior in the wrong direction and then
what you see in health care is this
struggle between sort of professional
responsibilities and a desire to do good
which I think most people have and their
economic incentives which push everyone
unfortunately in the other direction
how did insurance health care and health
all sort of become synonymous with one
another that may be the single most
dangerous element of our health care
debate the things that drive health
which we know are all lifestyle their
nutrition their exercise their stress
income education Public Safety all these
things drive health results far more
than health care and so that big thing
that we do in health care policy that's
most dangerous is we imply that making
sure everybody has the maximum out of
health care is essential for health when
one could better argue that diverting
18% of our GDP into health care has made
us significantly less healthy as a
country I always like to turn that
little thing on its head and say you
know what's amazing is that no developed
country's health seems to suffer no
matter how little it spends on health
care it may be the least important
factor in health and yet it's the one we
emphasize from there a lot of things go
wrong right from there we have a system
where much of the debate is about money
how do we pay for all the health care
people need and unfortunately when we
get into that discussion we miss a big
question which is if we pay for health
care in such a way that we take the
individual out are we going to subject
people to excess care and access
treatment which is a major cost sargent
a major cause of harm and injury and
poor health in itself are we gonna
subject people to sloppy treatment with
all the risk of error and also up to
death that we see and are we going to
subject people to unaccountable
treatment were the latest innovations
the latest benefits don't work their way
in the system the way they do with
everything else and there seems to be a
real desire on the part of many
Americans to not think about their
health care costs to not think about
paying for health care or buying it to
work for an employer who pays for health
care on their behalf how does that
factor into the to the
incentives that we sort of see playing
out in the system well in factors in
crucially because you know the
foundation of healthcare economics this
country is an article written by Kenneth
arrow and Kenneth arrow said health care
can never be a normal industry because
you'll buy whatever your doctor sells
you he's got all the expertise you're
desperate you're sick he's gonna tell
you how not to be sick you maybe even
save your life you'll buy anything there
can't be any normal marketplace
transaction sure so what's happened so
now we never asked him what it costs and
we buy everything in fact it's almost
what I would call arrows revenge
although I don't think he would regard
that very kindly but fixing the system
has made that thing worse we are less
skeptical more open you know there's a
terrific website that every American
should look at called the N and T com
every American should have before taking
a pill or having a treatment the n NT
takes all the numbers that you see that
are almost always misleading about
health care and translates it into a
single number how many people need to
take this pill for one person to benefit
how many people need to have this
operation for what this is one person
who's been prescribed this operation
it's astonishing
we have many pills that were look I'm
taking a statin for cholesterol if you
look at the N NT and admittedly I'm not
I'm contradicting my own point it's a
few people a few people benefit for
every hundred who take it and roughly
the same number or hurt because of other
risks that come from taking this pail
health care should be unbelievably cheap
right it's a capital intensive almost
zero marginal cost business and if you
look at any other industry that is a
terrible business model it's funny the
other day I was at a speech that the
politician made in which he said he'd
figured out a way that if we can you
know integrate care we can reduce the
number of MRIs performed and that'll
bring costs down and he and I were
sitting next to each other afterwards I
said you know that doesn't bring costs
down right so I said well the marginal
cost of doing MRI is 0 you already have
the machine you already have the
technician right what you're confusing
is price and cost
in healthcare we never talk about prices
we'd like to believe that somehow
there's some force that actually
determines what something costs that
it's independent of economics and that
has been devastating to prices some
healthcare you know there was a terrific
piece in the New York Times this week
about asthma drugs and way into the
story towards the back the reporter
who's done a terrific job I'm looking at
high prices and healthcare and she
recognized these are prices not cause
said the one thing the asthma drug
companies are determined to do is to
avoid their drugs ever being sold
over-the-counter they want them sold on
prescription keep the prices up not the
costs up yeah the prices up yeah
and in preventive care has also been
sort of a fundamental building block for
folks who talk about controlling cost if
we do more preventive care that will
actually bring down costs over time
what's your take on that is there much
there there well there is no there there
you know we know that most preventive
care is useless
thank goodness right most of us are
healthy and I think there's a there's
some you know the politics of health
care are very interesting it's almost a
combination of the incredibly naive and
the extraordinarily self-interested
becoming a coalition to do anything we
can to push up demand preventive care is
really interesting because it's an
example I think of where the Affordable
Care Act confused costs price invisible
cost so parental care was developing as
a very competitive segment because under
most people's high deductible plans they
were paying for most their preventive
care so you saw minute clinics
growing all over the country clinics and
drugstores in Walmart's and what have
you and the reality is the cost of
performing most tests is almost zero and
there's a lot of technologies out there
that will bring it down very close to
zero and more importantly let's you do
it at home why
well they had a chance to succeed
because you were paying for it the
administration or at least the
supporters of the Affordable Care Act to
be fair think preventive care should be
free to make sure nobody nowhere doesn't
get any total amount of it doesn't get
the total amount of
well the problem with that is all that
incentive to price preventive care
cheaply went out the window
the minute you said anybody who's
insured should never have to pay a penny
for productive care the incentive to
keep prices down was gone and I think
it's actually an interesting example of
what's happened in all of healthcare
look at Medicare in 1965 the average
senior spent 10% of his or her income on
health care and they were paying for all
of it
so we fast-forward almost 50 years of
Medicare the average senior pays only 5%
of their total health care bill 95% is
paid through Medicare right that 5% is
now almost 20% of their income they're
no better off financially it the
extremes are less people of fewer people
have extreme examples but all you've
done is you've enabled my disguise my
not knowing what something cost me my
crazy belief that someone else is really
paying for it right to allow the
providers to push up prices or what any
number of people watching now might
think to themselves as well that's
because of all the technology in
healthcare technology is driving up the
cost of health care but you you have a
different take on that as well
I I once did a Google search to see how
many articles have been written in the
previous year saying the technology a
driven up health care and then I tried
to imagine how many of those articles
were written on $400 laptops sure you
know it's an obvious confusion for
people technology does drive up the cost
of anything if you allow it to so if we
said you know everybody should have a
smartphone but we know smartphones are
expensive so anything above $300 the
government will pay for well your
smartphone would be nuclear-powered
right it would have it can't opener on
it it would do everything you can
imagine and technology will have driven
up those costs in people's minds the
issue in healthcare is different the
issue is do we have incentives for those
technologies that bring down costs and
prices which is most technology
including most healthcare technology
to be adopted by sellers providers we
don't do we have incentives for
technology that seems to push up prices
and costs to be adopted by providers yes
yeah and that's the difference and
that's what people miss the Reagan era
reform to bundle Hospital payments had
an enormous impact on hospital use in
this country most people aren't aware of
this but the average stay per Medicare
beneficiary in hospital number of days
has declined by 60% since then in
patient care is totally transform most
of it is short what did the hospital's
do in response they cut their prices
because demand declined by 60%
no they invested in things that push up
their costs so hospitals now say to
Medicare our costs are costs are 7x what
they were 30 years ago and the prices
you pay us are now 5x that's not what
other industries would have done now if
you go into a typical Hospital you see
less information technology than you do
at your Jiffy Lube it's not because
Congress pushed a few Lube to adopt
information technology it's because they
want to save money hospitals never had
an incentive to save money they have the
opposite incentive and that's why
technology seems to be pushing a price
Internet the Army's got a blood-clotting
technology it's a it's a it's a topical
did no hospital in America uses why it's
too cheap let's turn our attention to
the Affordable Care Act for a moment
obviously there are great many policies
there some of which we've sort of
discussed already what's sort of the
best and worst attribute of the
Affordable Care Act well I actually the
best attribute of the Affordable Care
Act is the basing of Medicaid on income
levels I think one of the great
dysfunctions of the Medicaid program is
that it becomes sort of the favored
disease or condition program as opposed
to what it needs to be which is a safety
net for those Americans who can't afford
health care I don't like the way
Medicaid functions but I think the idea
of saying look this is about helping
people can't afford health care afford
health care period is a real positive
you know if we're going to have a safety
net structure the way it's structured it
needs to be structured more simply
unfortunately the rest of the Affordable
Care Act is the opposite of simple it
takes a system that's already way too
complex way too hard for people to
understand and navigate through just
normal consumers just to navigate
through and makes it ever more
complicated so the greatest issue in
that apart from is making harder for us
to be patients and consumers of
healthcare is that we don't really know
what's gonna happen and neither do its
sponsors I don't think there's a lot of
genuine market incentives in the
Affordable Care Act I think the people
who wrote it think there are I think
most of them are so constricted it's so
narrow and so manipulated I think the
exchanges are a good example of this
that where's likely to see them depress
competition and all the benefits
competition bring as enable competition
you know the Affordable Care Act
although would try to do a lot of
different things in health care was most
interested in insurance expanding the
amount of insurance coverage both the
number of people covered and the type of
coverage itself there are obviously
positives in that unfortunately you know
the American system of insurance both
public and private is unique in that it
has no break the principle here is that
any care that's needed should be paid
for by your private insurer by your
public insurer for Medicare Medicaid
that is a principle no other country I
know cirrhosis yeah I mean you certainly
don't see that in places where there is
single payer insurance policies I mean
you have to stop somebody somewhere gets
to say no sure in the American system
and and I by the way I don't think this
is fixable so I think you have to it's
one of the reasons that I think you have
to have a greater role for consumer
because in the United States the
consumer is the only one that has
recognized authorities know sure you
know if you look at what's happened with
Medicare arguably Medicare is unleashed
this plague of medical sloppiness and
errors and excess care and the medical
as I said all these terrible things
there's not a senior citizenship senior
citizens political organization out
there that says please will somebody
administer this program to protect us
from health care sure sure not a single
one yeah and and I guess when you
approach health care you are a Democrat
but when you approach health care your
first instinct at this point is not
single-payer it is a market oriented
solution where
books are more responsible for more of
their own healthcare can you describe
what what yeah a system that works looks
like what I would like to see is a
straightforward simple truly universal
safety net which for me means that you
insure against what insurance can
actually do well without distorting the
market which is catastrophic air but we
can manage that part of it that really
isn't expected or predictable and as a
part of that we can create a system
that's truly Universal and look at those
who can't afford to be in the system and
actually give them the money to
participate beyond that we really do
need to unleash in health care those
forces that work in everything else
competition incentives for innovation
incentives for value need to satisfy a
customer need to be accountable to a
customer and the only way to do that is
to take some of the three trillion
dollars we're gonna spend on health care
give it back to the places it came from
because it was not magically invented
we're all paying into the system sure
give it back to the individuals carve
out as a safety net for all that which
is truly unpredictable and frankly over
time we have to have the discipline to
reduce that safety net to make it more
about what's catastrophic look
end-of-life care is the ultimate example
of this end-of-life care is very
expensive and as we all know many
hospitals or incentives do a tremendous
amount of it regardless of what the
patient wants I saw that with my own
father and I think any of us who have
older parents dread that very difficult
time where it feels like they're being
tortured by their therapeutic
institution and unfortunately we live in
a world where most of us are likely now
to have end-of-life care we're gonna
live long enough and be safe enough and
all those great things about living
today but you can't ensure for it
you can't ensure for something that's
gonna happen to everybody that is that
is the wrong model it's the wrong and
worse when you ensure for it it means
everyone demands too much of it and if
we all need it which is what health care
people talk about need then how does it
work how do you have a fire insurance
pool if everybody's house is gonna burn
down
you can't sure and that's the
fundamental problem with thinking about
health care is that we've taken it from
where insurance made a ton of sense
protecting us against the unexpected the
financially ruinous that the very
long-term health problem and making it
comprehensive so that it's a failing of
your health care plan of your health
care insurance if it doesn't fund the
equivalent of your oil change and you're
filling up the tank with gas we don't
ask auto insurance to do it we can't ask
health insurance to do it without so
distorting the health care economy we
get what we have today now there could
be someone listening to the conversation
who's thinking to themselves well you
know I haven't I have two children at
some point he needs his appendix removed
for tonsil tonsils removed this is gonna
cost this ten or fifteen thousand
dollars at a single pop or I have been
in a car accident very very difficult or
a loved one has the notion of thinking
about cost in a circumstance like that
is just a naphtha mo to them what would
you say to someone who raises a
challenge like that well I you know the
book begins with the story of what a
person starting work at my company today
will pilot will pour into the health
care system over her lifetime so I look
at a 23 year old starting out on our
classic PPO plan that that's sort of big
insurance plan with a low deductible the
old standard plan I look at how much
you'll pay in taxes how much her wages
will decrease because we're paying her
premiums where else does the money come
from how much she'll pay out of pocket
and it's extraordinary so this young
woman if she's the sole breadwinner for
her family and the cost of health care
goes up by zero over her lifetime which
by the way probably hasn't been true
just during our own conversation yeah
you know she's looking at putting a
million to it sure if she just puts in
what the Affordable Care Act estimates
are for cost growth over the next ten
years she'll put a million seven if
she's got a working spouse
they'll together put two and a quarter
million in now here's the punchline
they're not rich I have her as just a
normal middle-class family entry-level
salary doing what people have done in
this country forever she will wind up
putting in somewhere between 30 and 35
percent of her family income into health
care now she's not going to notice it
right because a lot of its gonna be
taxes and some of it'll be premiums we
pay and some and it'll be spread out
over so many different things but how
many Americans don't think they can
handle their family health care and some
of that $2 and the difference of course
is if it was our two and a quarter
million dollars that of appendectomy is
not gonna cost 10 grand not gonna be
priced at 10 grand because you can't
sell them there I'm very attracted to
what Singapore is done you know
Singapore has a very large involvement
for the government health care but it
does one thing that no other developed
country does is it mean it says at every
point of purchase the individual is the
customer and that effect is
transformative not just on price by the
way but also on service and safety III I
don't know if you know but Singapore
spends under 4 percent of GDP on health
care Wow making it by far the lowest in
the developed world and what's even more
interesting is the average Singaporean
and this is a country roughly the same
income per person in the United States
the average Singaporean is estimated to
have enough in his health savings
account after 20 years of the system to
pay for 11 hospitalizations Wow
it's amazing how quickly bringing the
consumer in look the device you're
carrying of a mini tablet would have
been inconceivable in the day of
mainframes when Medicare was created it
didn't happen because we said let's make
computer small it would happen because
somebody said I want to chase this guy
and get his business not just not just
the Defense Department and NASA's
business sure we need to do that in
healthcare we need more of it mouth care
another area which you don't discuss in
much detail in your book is the American
Medical Association which does in fact
have a monopoly on minting new doctors
and that that carries its own incentives
yes do you have any thoughts on on what
sort of reforms might be appropriate
there I saw one study which suggested
that medical doctors in the United
States both specialists and general
practitioners were being paid two to
three times more what their Oct Conner
parts were being compensated that that's
adding something like 50 billion dollars
a year to the cost of care well
yes I sent a concern sure it is a
concern but I think if you if you look
at it more broadly the fact that the
government's role in healthcare is not
just to help us pay for but actually to
be the customer both through Medicare
and Medicaid were directly by his
healthcare on the behalf of its
beneficiaries and in the way it
structures insurance where it comes
pretty close to doing so as well by
restricting what insurers can and cannot
buy there's an enormous number of places
where industrial interests have captured
the regulatory regime sure the very fact
that we have general hospitals and areas
where they can't perform operations and
enough scale to be any good at it is an
example of it you're right the fact that
most states restrict what other licensed
professionals can do to only doctors
pushes up their income right but let me
remind people of something that we've
forgotten there's a million doctors in
this country there's 15 million people
earning their living in health care so
doctors are 6% of the healthcare
workforce incentives matter everywhere
and there's no question that when you
look at for example just to go back to
yours
how does Medicare determine how much an
orthopedic surgeons time is worth versus
of primary care physicians they go to
the doctors arguably not the best place
to ask somebody about relative value
right I wish they'd do that in my
industry I gotta tell you I think
Americans are frightfully undersupplied
with gameshows and I'd like to see
Congress and and regulators intervene
I'd be better for their health I'm
inclined to agree yeah I mean it's all
about health care it's you know it'll be
the issue in the next election I'm
pretty sure but you know there's a lot
of places where there's that
intersection and they're dangerous you
know look at how our dialysis program
works dialysis is the one single payer
part of the American healthcare system
where the government essentially pays
for everything that any end-stage renal
disease sufferer has look at the history
of it it's an extraordinary history of
Industry capture and we see it
everywhere we are gonna have to face
something about our political system
it's extraordinarily responsive right
that's why there's so much lobbying
campaigns never end politicians spend
all their time raising money you know I
once wrote that
if we want our healthcare system to be
like Sweden's we can't adopt Sweden's
health care system we have got their
political system because the more power
that we give the government to buy stuff
the more sense it makes for me to lobby
the government to buy my stuff mm-hmm
and that really is what's happened in
healthcare is the government is now
running a trillion and a quarter dollar
economy as the direct customer that's a
lot of money not to be influenced by
Jeremy sure and you know as we talked
about earlier the Affordable Care Act
actually expands those opportunities
doesn't reduce it which is one reasons
I'm concerned about how it will really
work in practice so any good news on the
horizon well I think there is I actually
think we see it with our own employees
here so the biggest problem with the
development of markets and technological
innovation actually brought prices down
instead of raised them and created
therapeutic benefits instead of just
cost base has been not enough scale of
real consumers well that's changing very
fast we now have a significant
percentage of our workforce that really
thinks about the price the cost to them
of actually buying health care and we're
starting to see new business models
we're starting to see new technologies
take advantage of the fact that we have
price conscious consumers this is an
enormous benefit and in fact it may wind
up being the biggest accidental result
of the Affordable Care Act is that it
looks like to get subsidies on the
exchanges for companies to possibly
offer insurance is less than the
Cadillac tax alone that's we're gonna
see more and more cost sharing on the
island of health care people are focused
on oh my god does that mean somebody may
not get health care they meet in the
real economy what we know is going to
happen is that as you get a scale of
consumers a scale of cost value
motivated consumers you then have a
reason for providers and for business
models to seek them out there's tons of
technologies in health care that would
save cost
there's tons of say you want to look at
simple health care go to a clinic that
serves the undocumented or go to a
concierge practice that serves the rich
the undocumented and rich benefit from
two things they're both the only
customer there's no one behind them they
both opted out either voluntarily or
involuntarily the insurance system and
what do we see there simple
straightforward
face conscious care we're gonna see that
in more of our economy and it's gonna
create people say all the time where the
Bill Gates where the Steve Jobs you know
where the FedEx is where are the
Walmart's well there's never been enough
scale and customer to build those
business models models that emphasize
value true innovation you know service
and accountability I think we're gonna
get to a point where enough people pay
the first two thousand twenty five
hundred even ten thousand dollars out of
pocket that suddenly those those people
those because there's a lot of people
looking on it the Steve Jobs of health
care is coming he's soon gonna have a
big enough market to actually build an
innovative product and innovative
service and that's gonna be great for
health care David thanks so much for
your time the book again is catastrophic
care how American health care killed my
father it is a phenomenally well-written
and accessible book I commend it to you
please go out and read it for reason TV
I'm Camille Foster thanks so much for
joining us
you